hot breath so you can say that like when
people say hey you're a comedian tell me
a joke
i always tell them a joke because if i
just say
i don't do jokes i do stories what are
the odds of them coming to any of my
shows
zero but if i give them a joke that was
funny where are you playing
here there's an app on my phone i open
it up it's a form
they put in their email they hit send
with their first name they hit send
it goes they automatically get an email
response that leads them to a two or
three minute video here's a clip
you know enjoy then i'll send them
something else i just use uh i use
mailchimp
mailchimp oh and i create a link on i
have it on my evernote i just hit that
and it opens up the website with that
form on it
and they put it in and i say i'll invite
you to a show and it's my fan list
yeah uh think this happens all the time
oh you're a comedian
well tell me a joke and i'll tell them a
joke the joke is usually my ex who
cheated on me called me on halloween
she's like jerry i don't know what to
pretend to be for halloween
i said why don't you just just normally
and pretend you're in a committed
relationship
and they go that's funny where are you
playing right and it's that simple
you know and it's rather than i don't do
jokes i do stories the reason
most of us say that is because we're not
prepared